qu'est-ce que ça ah bonjour je te
dérange pas on voit pas du tout facteur
l'enjeu ça pour mon ça glisse ça roule
ça boume je me repose pour sûr
j'aimerais bien en faire autant
j'y pense casimir way une tente où doit
arriver pour toi en fin d'après midi au
bureau de poste à bout mais mais mais
c'est très bien mais je vais aller la
chercher nous plonge toujours que la
porterai dit je suis payé pour ça bon
ben merci facteur aller à tout à l'heure
que des malheurs cette formidable je
vais pas recevoir la visite du nid 45 je
me demande pourquoi elle arrive au
bureau de poste
enfin je me demande si c'est la tante
adélaïde la bavarde ou alors si bill la
coquette à moins que ce soit de la tâche
à la montagnarde ou ou marion là puisque
enfin bon je vais en profiter pour
donner un coup de balai heureusement que
je reçois des visites de temps en temps
sinon je ne ferais jamais les ménages
voilà
à léonard qu'est ce que tu fais je
réfléchis à quoi manière de m'y prendre
bon jouer un bon tour à ce prétentieux
de grouchy ah bon et tu as trouvé
quelque chose mais je crois avoir trouvé
tu vois je vais lui faire le coup de la
multiplication des pommes au oui oui
d'accord oui
le voile injustement
et bien mes bons amis mois oui
[Musique]
magicien yoldi astrologue averti
chacun de nous huit mois de repli
patience infinie chômage réduit
moi on fait des révisions je dis tu sais
même pas compter bonfoh léonard tu toi
tu te moques de moi je ne pose pas un du
tout un atout je répète que tu ne sais
pas quand on regarde cette pomme et 10
mois une pente plus une pomme ça fait
combien de prendre confiance et soeurs
fanta cela fait de pommes ça fait de
peindre moi je n'en vois toujours qu'une
tu sais compter comme tout le monde mais
tu ne sais pas compter comme un magicien
je vois où tu veux en venir d'accord bon
et bien voilà
c'était un peu étudiée de maintenant de
plus de risques bien cela va faire
quatre pommes attention
oui oui c'est ça la vie maintenant et
maintenant que plus 4 alors là rien de
plus facile regarde toi
[Musique]
tu brûles this is it oui oui c'est ça
continue ça me fait rire et maintenant
huit
+88 évite à temps et éviter bien cela va
faire ça à ce pauvre regarde bien or
si bien voilà un profond que c'est un
vrai bon maintenant écoute moi à moi de
te poser une question que - combien y
at-il de pommes dans un kilo et qui nous
mais je ne sais même pas combien pèse un
kilo tu ne sais pas combien peu de culot
et bien tu vas le savoir regardez bien
attention
mais qu'est ce que c'est ce truc qu'est
ce que c'est et bien c'est un poids de 1
kg qui pèse exactement milgram oui oui
mais était ma pomme répond qu'est ce que
je vais manger maintenant eh bien tu
m'auras ce que tu veux mais je ne
conseille pas le poids de 1 kg ce serait
un petit peu indigeste
[Rires]
ça va
bonjour julie françois faire un jour
j'ai du courrier pour vous on
a dû courir doucement mais il pas la
peine de vous presser un je me suis tant
que j'ai je suis tout mon temps asseyez
vous
vous savez je n'ai pas envie de me
battre le record de mon confrère le
facteur alphonse de mon chef plutôt à
non non non moi je suis pas pareil c'est
vrai je prends mon travail d'une autre
manière c'est vrai je m'en vais tout
comme pour me promener à travers les
chemins là mais les poumons se
remplissent de l'odeur des des lavandes
mes yeux mes yeux s'émerveillent devant
tant de beauté tondeuse de couleur si
harmonieusement dessinée à travers la
campagne et alors qu'un tel un de mes
clients m'offre gentiment à boire soit
une orangeade ou une citronnade nageuse
je ne lui refuse pas c'est vrai je ne
dis pas non pour ne pas le faire de la
peine à accepter alors oui mais
j'accepte c'est ça mais en principe tout
le monde offre quelque chose mais n'a
cité
quelques-uns oublie parfois oui
oui
bon eh bien mes amis gérer je vais
continuer ma tournée
avait il le faut au revoir un facteur va
tourner à l'électeur
mais restez avec nous fait
pourquoi
8,3 km 500 et sur le chemin qui mène à
la maison de monsieur beauchesne soleil
tape très fort dans la portion oui vous
savez alors secteur vous n'allez pas
partir sans boire quelque chose
[Musique]
une grenadine jeu lige gens meurent dans
vit une grande hâte emile one peut
l'avoir demandé tout de suite vous savez
j'ai été élevé d'une manière assez
stricte je n'ose pas demander alors je
me demande oria jeu mais seulement un
petit peu sur la voie par quelques
légères allusion à remercier julien
aussi bien
aux
halles est bonne et bien fraîche
c'était discret pas vrai
j'y pense c'est aujourd'hui qu'arrive la
tante de casimir
mais nous n'étions pas au courant bon
ben vous le savez maintenant bon alors
j'y vais mais je vous reverrai dans la
journée au revoir et merci un
intercalaire d'accord tonnes de casino
oui il faut absolument la recevoir digne
lui mettre une jolie robe bien votre moi
aussi
bon voilà ça ira comme ça
on peut entraver kazim est un facteur
vous emmener ma tante et oui kazemi
est bien fait là tu ne préfère pas qu'on
la laisse d'or mais enfin pourquoi
voulez vous laisser ma tante dehors
parce que sa place est plutôt à
l'extérieur tout à l'intérieur
qu'est ce qui lui prend s'était mis les
campagnes vous vous avez bien oui vous
n'avez pas pris un coup de soleil sur la
tête alors tu vois j'ai la casquette qui
me protège bon alors je vous en prie
pour la seconde fois fait en prime et en
robe comme tu voudras casimir
alors
voilà casimir a tissé par les joueurs tu
attends vous l'avez labeaume et factures
m'enfin vous vous êtes fous et valve a
étouffé il ouvrira un nouveau bateau
est vraiment là
pour une belle tente de plage c'est une
belle tente de plage casimir
regarde regarde l'étiquette c'est ton
cousin théodule qui te l'envoyer au et
moi qui étais persuadé que c'était l'une
des soeurs de main
c'est la lettre au bon dieu l'a replacé
au bureau de poste je avoir un petit
succès
ah ça non
[Musique]
alors
oui ah bon bon bah oui oui si vous
voulez oui
julie et françoise viens de voir ma
tante il ce n'est qu'une tante de place
je vais avoir l'air mal à moi il faut
que je trouve une solution
léonard morieux un sens large et besoin
le poney jazz et à dieu ce jeu et bien
voilà écoute il va falloir faire
je te propose cette
[Musique]
multi ghz et enfile dame pour me faire
passer pour une de ses débuts remarqués
c'est rigolo quand on lit des limites il
a tellement peur que ça ne marche pas
kim a préféré s'en aller
je vais changer ma voix je suis sûr que
ça va marcher comme sur des roulettes
casini c'est nous portrait ou bien sûr
montrer mes petits gdj l'egypte tu
passeras chanel c'est dans l'autre sens
comme ça voilà les enfants toujours
bonjour madame
quasi n'y avait pas là ah non non il est
sorti il avait une course urgente à
faire avant je suppose que vous êtes sa
tante à elle-même
bonjour chère madame
très bien ce jeune homme
me vous imaginez on pas tout à fait
comme ça non mais nous sommes quand même
on chantait de faire votre connaissance
et moi tout va beaucoup parler en bien
j'espère en bien eux vous êtes laquelle
de ses tantes
je n'avais pas prévu cela
je suis je suis un lot de pia voilà ton
pillages guilbeault de nous est bien
temps pliable je vous ai apporté le tew
c'est ce que j'ai vu que ça mais lula tu
puisses y écrit 8 il était vous êtes bon
voilà et quant à moi je vous ai apporté
un bouquet de fleurs des champs où vous
êtes très gentil jeune homme juge
philippe houzé là
comment se fait-il que vous ne trouviez
dans la malle de léonard les pieds aussi
parce que c'est parce qu'il n'avait pas
de cette chaise pour tous leurs
biens gelés qu'est ce que c'est que ce
gros que lui je sais pas moi vous le
savez vous tente pliable
ça c'est ma soeur la toile de plage de
casimir
[Musique]